la semaine en bonne compagnie Madeleine
blémorin Sébastien Bovet chef de bureau
respectivement Ottawa et Québec bonsoir
cher collègues bonsoir allons-y avec
l'élément un peu plus frais de la
journée qui est cette information cette
confirmation du départ à terme après
leur mandat de Mesdames Blais et mécan
Sébastien au terme d'une semaine très
difficile pour le gouvernement de
Monsieur le goût avec le dossieren oui
comme si l'idée de laisser couler
l'information selon laquelle mesdames
mécan et Blais allait plus être
candidate à l'époque candidate allait
faire partir les problèmes ou la
controverse dans laquelle
moi ça me fait penser à un enfant avec
qui on joue à cache-cache vous savez
quand on joue à cache-cache avec un
enfant des fois il va se mettre comme ça
les mains devant le visage puis il va
passer qu'on le voit plus que c'est
caché on voit encore c'est comme si il y
a quelqu'un au gouvernement probablement
au cabinet du premier ministre qui a
passé à avoir la brillante idée de se
dire si on laisse couler le fait que
mesdames blé mécan ne seront pas
candidates les problèmes de notre
semaine vont partir parce que les gens
vont se dire ben vous voyez de toute
façon les personnes qui sont autour au
milieu de cette tomate reviendront pas
en politique
puis vous savez le moment où un député
annonce son départ de la politique c'est
un moment en principe sacré c'est son
moment c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est très difficile de faire confirmer
en général qu'un député va s'en aller
parce que tout le monde autour de ce
député le protège pour dire un moment
donné il va pouvoir se parler s'exprimer
assez comme étant aux gens de sa
circonscription aux gens qui ont
travaillé avec lui à la population en
général pour dire j'ai fait mon bout et
c'était assez ici ça tombe dans le
journal en une Journal de Québec du
Journal de Montréal que les deux vont
s'en aller c'est comme briser leur
moment d'une certaine façon et leur
réaction sur Twitter on dit pas mal
c'est à dire que elle madame madame
mécan dit j'aurais souhaité l'annoncer
j'aurais souhaité l'annoncer aux
citoyens de mon côté en premier c'est ce
qu'elle dit en commençant son tweet puis
madame Blais dit elle aussi que elle va
s'en aller après un engagement politique
mais le retouite un article de la presse
qui dit que les deux ont été surprises
d'apprendre ça dans les journaux ce
matin
et on verra rapidement il y a un peu de
temps pour tellement de choses à dire et
analyser à décortiquer dans quelle
mesure cette semaine-ci Sébastien avec
tout ce qui a été dit écrit et tout ce
qu'on a appris à travers Thomas Gerbais
pour avoir un effet sur l'élection
partielle de lundi dans la
circonscription de Marie-Victorin est-ce
que ça sera est-ce qu'on doit avoir ça
comme un baromètre de la perception du
public face à la gestion du gouverne le
goût de la pandémie on verra quels sont
les résultats lundi mais ce qu'on croit
comprendre c'est que ça va être une
course ou un résultat serré entre la
coalition à Québec et le Parti québécois
je vous dis ça mais en même temps le
taux de participation va être
déterminant la dernière fois qu'il y a
une partielle de Marie-Victorin c'était
en 2016 il y avait 25% de taux de
participation c'est famélique alors
est-ce que les de Marie-Victorin va
vouloir sanctionner le gouvernement pour
ce qui s'est passé cette semaine est-ce
qu'ils vont vouloir avoir une députée
qui est avec le gouvernement ça ça reste
à voir mais c'est sûr que la semaine a
été très mauvaise puis nous on est dans
la bulle est-ce que est-ce que les
électeurs de ma Victorin ont porté une
attention particulière à suivre tous les
courriels les textos les attaques des
uns et des autres cette semaine une
chose qui est sûr par contre les gens
veulent que savoir ce qui s'est passé
lors de la première vague de la pandémie
est-ce que ça va se refléter dans le
vote de Marie-Victorin c'est possible on
verra mais en même temps Marie-Victorin
il y a plusieurs tests qui s'articulent
en même temps il y a les tests pour
laque sa gestion de la pandémie
peut-être aussi
les gens qui sont tannés en ce moment de
toutes les mesures de la covid donc la
CAC avait déjà eu une érosion de son
vote même si elle reste très dominante
au Québec il y avait quand même une
érosion dans les sondages donc il y
avait déjà un test pour la CAQ avant
même toute cette controverse cette
semaine il y avait aussi un test pour le
Parti québécois est-ce qu'il est encore
capable de conserver un siège comme
celui de marie-victorien donc c'est
difficile de résumer toute la l'élection
partielle à un seul enjeu à celui de du
CHSLD aussi dramatique soit-il
exactement alors qu'on voit ici les
résultats d'un des sondages les plus
récents effectués un des coups de son
les plus récents effectués dans cette
circonscription voilà ici la carte à 43%
devant le Parti québécois et Monsieur
Nantel évidemment le Parti québécois
s'accroche à cet espoir et donc à cette
circonscription Sébastien tous les gens
sont des sondage vont voter ce sera pas
le cas alors si le taux de participation
est faible quelle est la meilleure
machine électorale sur le terrain est-ce
que c'est celle de Pierre dentelle du
Parti québécois qui a des racines
profondes dans la circonscription ou
celle de la carte la carte a mis le
paquet ils ont envoyé des ministres ils
ont envoyé des conseillers politiques
toutes les fin de semaine pour essayer
de faire convaincre les gens de voter
pour la coalition Québec ça va être
intéressant alors passons au budget
maintenant qui a été présenté par Madame
Freeland premier budget avec Antoine de
fond cette alliance entre libio libéraux
et neodémocrate je sais Madeleine que
vous avez dit que ce budget n'était pas
si Orange que ça n'est-ce pas c'est ce
qu'on aurait le plan d'antenne ça c'est
véritablement une influence
néo-démocrate c'était le gain principal
de ces du parti néo-démocrate dans ce
mariage partie libéral partie ou
démocrate et ça se retrouve dans le
budget et c'était aussi le parle de test
je parlais de test tout à l'heure pour
l'élection partielle c'était aussi un
test pour ce mariage là à savoir est-ce
que ça tiendrait bon juste au début de
cette lune de miel ou de ce voyage de
noces vraisemblablement oui c'est la
suite qui va être un petit peu plus
difficile pour l'Alliance néo-démocrate
partie libérale parce que le détail de
ce qui doit être fait par la suite il
n'a pas été véritablement conclu c'est
la première année là qui avait été
véritablement détaillée dans l'entente
par la suite va probablement falloir
négocier mais il y a eu cette teinte
orange avec le plan dentaire sinon c'est
un budget qui est libéral et c'est un
budget qui est libéral mais on a été
habitué à un parti libéral un peu plus
dépensier depuis le début de du règne
Trudeau avec ce budget Freeland son
deuxième elle ne dépense pas toutes les
marges de manœuvre qu'elle a réussi à
dégager au cours des derniers mois
encore en raison de l'inflation ça ça
rapporte des revenus au gouvernement des
taxes en raison aussi de l'économie qui
qui tourne rondement en ce moment et ce
qui génère des revenus entre autres
grâce aux revenus d'emploi par exemple
mais les provinces auraient quand même
voulu avoir un peu plus de détails ou de
sous à l'intérieur de ces trans fameux
transferts en santé le trudôme Justin
Trudeau aujourd'hui a rejeté les
critiques
pour lesquelles il a fait la sourde
oreille aux demandes des provinces
oui mais on a hâte de voir quand même
comment vont se dérouler les
négociations parce que dans le budget
d'hier il y avait non seulement pas de
nouveau transferts où les transferts
souhaités par les provinces mais il y
avait aussi des petites pointes envoyées
aux provinces en disant bon quand on se
compare au pays de l'OCDE on dépense
plus par
rapport à la taille de notre économie
pour la santé or il y a des moins bons
résultats entre autres pour ce qui est
de l'accès à la santé donc une façon de
dire vous en faites pas assez avec
l'argent qu'on vous verse alors si on
veut inverser davantage va falloir que
vous vous amélioriez votre vos
performances je voudrais que ça met la
table à des négociations qui vont
peut-être être un peu difficiles Alexis
surtout que là l'argent est pas là puis
que les conditions puis que déjà les
critiques sont formulées je suis pas sûr
que c'est une ce que c'est bien reçu du
côté de chez Sébastien Bovet de
dans le gouvernement le goût notamment
la réaction la réaction du gouvernement
ça a été dire occasion manquer ça dit
tout Sonia Lebel a tweete ça hier soir
en disant l'occasion a été ratée
d'augmenter les transferts en santé la
demande du gouvernement du Québec et de
toutes les provinces en tout cas pour
l'instant c'est d'augmenter les
transferts en santé alors on se prépare
à des négociations qui vont être
difficiles dans le petit lexique de la
politique au Québec une bonne chicane
avec le gouvernement fédéral c'est
payant en principe électoralement il y a
des élections qui s'enviennent au Québec
j'ai un petit bémol par contre cette
fois-ci parce que oui ça peut être
payant et littéralement d'affronter le
gouvernement fédéral puis de défendre
les champs de compétences mais quand il
est question de la santé donnée de
meilleurs soins à la population après
être sorti d'une pandémie auprès de
15000 Québécois sont morts là c'est
14500 aux dernières décompte je pense
est-ce que les gens vont pas se dire ben
prends-le l'argent finance son réseau de
la santé s'il y a des conditions
rattachées à ça si ça donne de meilleurs
choix pourquoi pas je suis pas sûr que
c'est aussi
payant cette fois-ci d'affronter le
fédéral en disant on va refuser votre
argent où on veut pas de votre argent
s'il y a des conditions c'est peut-être
le calcul que fait juste un Trudeau en
effet l'argent est pas sur la table
encore c'est pas comme si François
Legault était en train de dire moi
j'attends avant de le prendre cet
argent-là je veux pas de je veux pas de
conditions il le dit bien qu'il ne veut
pas de conditions mais il demande des
sommes que le gouvernement fédéral pour
le moment ne pas été prêt à verser mais
on parle de négociation comment ça
pourrait se faire une province à la fois
comme on l'a vu dans d'autres dossiers
c'est un peu ça la question qui demeure
en suspens n'est-ce pas c'est une
stratégie que le gouvernement Trudeau a
adopté entre autres pour les premiers
transferts en santé qui ont été négociés
plutôt là dans un premier mandat Trudeau
ça a été aussi la même stratégie pour ce
qui est des services de garde et jusqu'à
maintenant ça a été payant pour le
gouvernement fédéral donc je vois pas
pourquoi il changerait une recette
gagnante pour eux alors pour la semaine
prochaine vous vous y préparez comme
toujours qu'est-ce que vous voyez ça va
être plutôt tranquille à tawa et c'est
relâches parlementaires la semaine
prochaine ça sera pas tranquille pour le
gouvernement pour pour Justin Trudeau
pour ses ministres exactement ça a déjà
commencé aujourd'hui donc un budget
c'est une chose après ça on veut faire
aimer son budget
promouvoir par exemple le plan logement
dans le budget c'est la mesure phare
aujourd'hui ils étaient en Ontario en
train de faire justement ça promouvoir
le plan logement d'un contenu dans ce
budget Sébastien de votre côté lundi
soir on verra si on veille tard si c'est
serré mais comme le disait si bien
Madeleine il y aura des choses à
analyser de cette élection partielle
dans Marie-Victorin pour tous les partis
qui ont un défi à relever dans cette
élection partielle ça va être
passionnant comme toujours surtout quand
vous êtes là pour nous en parler en vous
remerciant beaucoup Madeleine Sébastien
bonne fête semaine bon weekend au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI